joining us here on the mercedes benz
vans phone line is a it's very rare for
a coach to have an opportunity to have
back-to-back 10-win seasons in the nfl
when
the second season in which it would be
back-to-back they had just one win in
their first eight games but such is the
case for the miami dolphins getting set
to try and win their seventh in a row on
monday night football against the new
orleans saints and the head coach in his
third year in south florida joining us
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
brian flores how you doing coach
doing great how are you i'm doing i'm
doing just terrific and i appreciate you
asking so uh let's jump right into it um
when you are one in seven what do you
tell a team that's one in seven i
imagine you're not in that position too
often well you know i think uh
you know my message to to our group was
you know look this is a
there's a lot of parody in this league
so
there's a there's a small margin for
error um and i think we were on the
wrong side of that that margin for
you know a few games this year early in
the season so
um you know i think my message to our
guys is just continue to work the way
they have been working but also
um you know we just needed to uh
you know just play better situationally
uh but but at the end of the day just
stick together keep doing what we're
doing and um and you know that things
return i guess it is the ultimate one
game at a time approach right i mean
that's such a cliche but in this in your
case it seems to have worked
here right yeah i mean i think that's
always been you know kind of my approach
and our approach here is you know one
play at a time one game at a time one
week at a time um and really try to put
our focus on you know the task at hand
and not think about
um
you know what's happened in the past or
what what may happen in the future
um and i think that's to me that's i've
always felt like that's the way to get
you know the best results in the present
so
um that's kind of my message to the team
at all times was there a moment in a
game or maybe one that we didn't see
watching miami dolphins football where
you and your staff thought okay here we
go like this is this is the turning
point this is the pivot this is where
we're beginning to play football like we
know we can play it
well you know obviously it's probably on
our last you know in the buffalo game um
you know we lost that game but i think
you know we have been playing headstroke
been struggling for uh a few weeks prior
to that
and you know the first half of that game
you know buffalo's got a great team um
and uh you know we had played up to our
uh capabilities you know in the first
half and really into the into the second
half as well um and right then i felt
like you know
we were starting to
um
uh
you know turn the page on what was a
tough start to the season and um you
know i think we've uh we've played you
know fairly well since so
it's interesting so coach whose team is
on a win streak you're pointing to a
loss was it the week two is that what we
were referring to the home game
the one at buffalo on on halloween
you're you're affected
i think you know as the season
progresses you know you always want to
you know my thing is i just want to
watch us you know improve
um
and i think you know at the beginning of
the season there was uh
you know since
we we
weren't we weren't improving and then i
think you know
we're having good practices and
uh playing hard and giving great effort
um
but you know there was just a mistake
here we just weren't playing
complimentary football and i think in
that game in the buffalo game it was a
loss
but it just felt like we were
kind of moving in the right direction
head coach brian flores of the miami
dolphins getting set to take on the
saints on monday night football how is
tua improved in your estimation well i
think he's got you know much better
command of the offense
his leadership has improved immensely
his preparation
he's uh i think every time he steps out
on the field he gets a little bit better
um
still developing but he's a hard-working
kid it's very important to him and um
i'm pleased with with his growth this
season well i mean at any time i've ever
been around him you just sense it
the word it right he's got it he's he's
he exudes it whatever the it is and
only in the good way when you say he's
improved his leadership how how how has
that uh come to the fore
i think it's just uh just you know just
being more comfortable
uh you know
within the offense um
you know last year i'm coming off of the
injury
you know getting
a new playbook
i think he's just a much more
comfortable um
talks to his receivers more talks to the
offensive line more just take more more
command of the offense and
oh that's helped us i think yeah and of
course i assume he takes coaching really
well i mean coming from the from his
world of nick saban right absolutely
absolutely does he's a great kid and uh
he asks a lot of questions he tries to
be a sponge
um to get as much information as you can
so we can take and uh you know to put
our team in
as good a position as possible and i'll
give you the floor on xavier howard uh
your pro bowler and uh what he has done
and how he is playing and uh some of the
plays that he has made for you this year
you could point to as uh another turning
point i know obviously you know your
team better than i do but uh
he's been stupendous um
i'll give you the floor on on how he has
led that charge on the other side of the
ball for you next is just a great player
um
and that's uh that's he's a great player
he's a leader on this team
um
and
he's made he made a lot of big plays for
us
you know some big games and um
and i can't say enough good things about
him you know you know just you know
congrats to him for making another pro
bowl and
um
like he's just he just he's just a
playmaker at the end of the day that's
really what it goes down to and um
he's just a great great great player in
history brian flores miami dolphins head
coach and then before we just jumped a
little bit into the monday night game in
itself
um if you could wave a wand coach and
change a rule
in the nfl
which would that be
for you
yes
yes
change any rule in the nfl you're like
you know what this would be a good thing
to just get out of the game or bring
into the game which what would that be
for you
for me
[Music]
i i don't think there's gonna be this is
fine this is just between us coach this
is fine free conversation you know what
i'm saying
i'm stumped come on there's not one that
you're standing on the sideline and
you're like every single time it gets
called you're like come on yeah i mean
probably the uh drop of weight on the
quarterback
right
because there's no way to fix there's no
way to stop that's what you're saying
yeah yeah i mean you know that's a
little bit subjective on whether or not
you rolled off or didn't well how about
this then because this is something that
i've been pounding the table for um
that that uh sky judge or whatever that
we're calling it hawkeye or 345 or the
new york eye in the sky that every
single one of these 15 yarders just like
what you talked about
that the flag goes down and then the
refs huddle up and they're talking but
they're really having somebody in new
york city take a look to see if somebody
did land their weight on it or did make
contact head to head or did do what is
uh is being said or in the case of
you know a face mask that wasn't called
would you be in favor of something like
that all 15 yarders being reviewed like
that what do you think
i mean i don't would i be in favor of it
yes sir
i mean yeah i mean if if the rules was
then yeah i'd be in favor of it okay
just to make sure that you know that all
those players are
all right because those are big
penalties and big plays yeah i mean they
continue drives your defense might not
get off the field you know or your
offense doesn't stay on the field when
something gets missed you know i'm just
yeah that that that's that's my that's
what i'd pound the table for really you
know you take that competition to me you
did this look you take it to the
michigan man at the top of the flow
chart there okay
and tell them this you spoke to another
michigan man well you did you could do
that he'll understand you know we're
just there i'll do that oh by the way oh
my gosh uh my team's coming to uh your
your stadium and stephen ross's team's
coming
no i don't think so you know
there's my day job at the nfl network
that kind of prevents that sort of thing
but maybe you could just leave a note
there for me would you do that you know
for the team or harbaugh
you don't know harbaugh at all do you do
you know him
no no i don't okay
but
not jim i'm literally now throwing darts
okay so let's get into uh the saints the
biggest challenge you've been you've
been circling
on film that you care to share with us
going into this game for your
preparation this week is what
well i mean defensively this is one of
the best groups in the league
um
i think dennis allen does a just a
terrific job you know with the defense
um i think he's an excellent coach i
think they've got a lot of great players
uh good rush good cover guys good um
good scheme so i mean this is gonna be a
major challenge for us from that that
butt standpoint and then um you know
tayson hill and his ability
um you know as a runner and a scrambler
um i think that that poses a lot of
issues for us as well um so
this is a talented team and
we've got all cut out for us so
you know we've got to do a good job in
practice we got to do the job preparing
and um
and obviously the the environment is
going to be uh electric so
we're kind of dealing with that you know
as a young team um
and i don't think i'm not sure how many
of our guys have been you know
uh
you know you know this type of
atmosphere so
this would be a major challenge for us
right i know if there's anybody who
would know how difficult it is to shut
out brady would be somebody who's had a
front row seat to a lot of his games
like you used to so when you saw that on
film what did you see
what did you see uh i mean i just saw a
consistent uh
consistently physical play consistent
uh uh
coverage rush and they kind of just put
all of it together
and played a 60 minute ball game
where they just apply pressure on every
snap and you know that's kind of where
they're placed out it's aggressive it's
physical
really on both sides of all three sides
of the ball well good luck to you and
your team i look forward to watching you
on monday night football and i hope this
is the first of many
many different conversations here how
how has your family handled the fame of
being in your draft room a couple of
years ago i've never spoken about that
did you have to tamp down
the egos in your household after all
that yeah absolutely you know my son
puts uh sunglasses on the next day
i don't want people to recognize me how
how old your son now how was he now uh
they're eight and seven okay your sons
are now eight and seven my dad my
daughter's four i'm gonna get her on
there nick well good there you go well i
mean hopefully you don't have any too
many reasons to be drafting from your
house anymore but you know i mean
that was uh that was quite something
your family certainly
front and center that here that is for
sure so yeah thanks for the time coach
really appreciate it best of luck to you
on monday night and like i said hope
this is the first of many times you're
on this show appreciate it thanks rich
you got it that's brian flores miami
dolphins head coach right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here